Donald Trump completely face planted and
humiliated himself in a disastrous new
interview from yesterday with right wing
radio host Hugh Hewitt let's look at a
couple moments here on a Hugh Hewitt's
program Donald Trump tried to claim that
it's very common to send an alternate
slate of electors to claim oh give our
states electoral votes to the guy who
lost the truth is it's not common but
Trump says it as if he's telling the
truth because he lies every second they
are attempting I think to indict people
for plans to select alternative electors
on one sec have you received a Target
letter Mr President no I haven't at all
and frankly when you look at alternate
slates that way that's been done for
decades and decades many many years now
that's a lie what has been done for
decades and decades is that
you have people identified and the
people are aware okay
if Biden wins you would be you would be
a Biden elector
other people are told if Trump wins you
would be a trump elector what is not
done is that Biden wins the Biden
electors are notified it's y'all because
Biden won and then Republicans start
calling random people who were not going
to be the Trump slate of electors to say
Hey what if we just show up anyway that
it is not true that that is typical
alternate slices are actually common I
wasn't involved with alternate slates
but I can tell you many people have been
for many many years doing alternate
slates in fact uh your friend Tucker
Carlson did a story on it last night
have you standards way of you know
working elections yeah completely untrue
completely untrue Donald Trump asked
during this interview about what if the
doj indicts you and again Donald Trump
alludes to violence take a listen to
this this is incredible you know the old
saying uh prosecutor can indict a ham
sandwich if they want to I'm just asking
if there is such a prosecutor and they
indict you would that deter you from
running for president again I don't
think
would stand for it and as you know if a
thing like that happened I would have no
prohibition against running you know
that you've already I do and that's what
I want people to understand that would
not take you out of the Arena it would
not but I think if it happened I think
you'd have problems in this country the
likes of which perhaps we've never seen
before whoa I don't think the people of
the United States would stand for it
what kind of problems Mr President I
think that have big problems big
problems I just don't think they'd stand
for it they will not they will not sit
still and stand for this ultimate of
hoaxes that is a threat
that is a threat from the former
president to unleash his own supporters
on the country
that is what that is
um one other uh clip that we're going to
take a look at here do you feel like the
Department of Justice is trying to
indict you Mr President
well there is no reason that they can
because other than if they're just sick
and deranged which is always possible
because I did absolutely you've seen the
legal papers absolutely nothing wrong
and there's no reason that they can do
that and I'll tell you what I would have
said there's no way they can raid a
house either because you know us Fourth
Amendment stuff and what they did is
yeah they everything was signed off on
everything was legal it was not an
illegal search and seizure terrible and
uh I don't think the people are going to
stand for it if you noticed the poll
numbers are the highest they've ever
been the people are not going to stand
for this stuff they've wept so then he
goes back into that entire uh entire
thing and uh then lastly asked about the
classified documents Trump claims he
Declassified Declassified everything he
took to Mar-A-Lago except his lawyers
are not making that argument in court
because it's an absurd argument Mr Patel
said he witnessed you giving verbal
orders to declassify the papers that end
up at Mar-A-Lago do you remember making
those orders that's correct and not only
that I I think it was other people also
were there but I have the absolute right
to declassify yeah and of course as
we've said before the classification
status of these documents is not
relevant to all of the crimes Trump is
being investigated for you can't just
look at a whole bunch of documents and
say declassify even William Barr
admitted that but the big highlight here
or low light is Trump threatening to
unleash his followers on the country
that was a signal you're not going to
stand for it you're going to go crazy in
the streets if they indict me very
dangerous stuff something in your home
that you use every day contributes to
deforestation and climate change and
that's toilet paper in the U.S alone
over 30 million trees each year are
required to meet toilet paper demands
contributing to deforestation soil
erosion devastating loss of biodiversity
our sponsor real paper makes sustainable
toilet paper that is 100 made from
bamboo a bamboo stock keeps growing it
can be harvested forever it means that
the soil and the ecosystem aren't
disrupted no carbon removing trees are
cut down the paper industry has a
massive effect on deforestation and
climate change but you alone using
bamboo toilet paper can make a positive
impact because for the toilet paper that
just one American uses in their lifetime
hundreds of trees are required put an
end to that right now with real paper
the best part is this stuff is really
great it's just normal Soft toilet paper
real paper loves the David Pacman show
they're giving my audience 30 off your
first order and free shipping when you
go to realpaper.com Pacman and use the
code Pacman at checkout the link is down
below